Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
I have to prepare more for podcasts and,
um,
I feel like I personally,
I mean,
it,
it's,
it's as much as out of concern from my guests as well.
Like I,
I just,
you know,
this is a high wire act,
but I want a net normally so that people feel free to be totally on guarded
because they know that if we have a spazz attack,
we can,
you know,
uh,
even uttering spazz attack,
we'll screw.
So some people's careers.
Right.
He actually had a conversation about a podcast that I talked to you about one of
your podcasts.
We said that you actually started it over,
you started at,
let's try this again.
Let's just start from scratch.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
maybe,
I think it would,
I don't think it would be sporting to,
um,
say which podcasts that was.
But yeah.
So I had a podcast that went completely into the ditch for the first half hour.
I mean,
just brutal.
And I said,
listen,
there's a really,
there's a good conversation for us to have here and now I know how bad Lee this
can go.
All right.
So like now I know just where the track is,
I have to struggle to keep the train on.
And so we're going to reboot,
we're going to start again and we'll see what happens.
And you know,
the podcast was,
was not perfect and I got some criticism for it,
but people didn't understand that we were like,
you know,
w we had,
uh,
you know,
we had,
I had,
I had seen the pit of alligators and didn't want to fall in like,
you know,
well,
it made more sense though when you told me that because I'm like,
okay,
it was heated before you even got to go because you'd already gone through a
half an hour of back and forth.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I think people need to understand what it's like to do one of these things too
because uh,
you know,
you do it so often,
it becomes pretty,
you're so good at talking,
you're such a good orator and you're so articulate that it comes off smooth and
easy.
You're just having a conversation with someone but you're always considering the
fact that people are listening to this.
You're always saying,
how do I,
how do I get more out of him or her?
How do I take this in and how do I get this person to expand upon this?
How do I,
you know,
how do I make this something,
make something out of this?
This is one of the things that I felt with Jack because he was talking in this
way and we're,
we're really working hard on fixing all these issues.
I'm like,
oh Jesus,
I got to change my gears here and try to figure out,
cause like it's almost like we'd have to restart again every time a question
would be answered.
He would stop talking and I'd go okay to next to so long.
You forgot what you asked.
Well,
it's almost like I have to restart the momentum of it,
but,
well,
again,
I'm,
I'm totally,
I'm that kind of speaker,
so,
you know,
I,
that wasn't a problem and I didn't know what he talked like I'd never heard him
talk ever.
So hearing him talk there and in talking to him live,
you know,
I mean some people are fucking effortless.
Some people,
like Ilan took a while,
like we had to start drinking now.
That was brutal.
But so like,
but that,
I mean,
you know how much I tried to micromanage that behind the scenes,
right?
Like I was all in your grill.
I'm trying to figure that out.
And you know,
you guys basically broke all the rules.
I,
I have thought I laid down a penny.
Ilan did it,
cause he'll,
Ilan tweeted,
y'all be on Joe's podcast Thursday night at nine o'clock.
But you know,
I mean,
I,
I didn't want you guys to go live.
I wanted,
I wanted you to both have a chance to say,
wait a minute.
This is smoking a blunt.
Really the thing we want to be doing here.
Uh,
so you know,
you didn't take my advice and it was what it was when we were drunk.
By the time the weed came out,
that was what's,
what's interesting to me is we were drinking from the beginning of the podcast,
we started drinking whiskey.
We both had two or three glasses of whiskey right before the weed came out.
Nobody cared.
The fact that the CEO of Tesla was trunk,
right?
Like no one cared about that.
I mean it wasn't drunk,
but he shouldn't have been driving.
I don't know if that was obvious.
I don't know if they saw that you were drinking.
It was obvious in the beginning and pouring the whiskey.
I mean it was on the table.
We had ice.
We're clinking glasses.
Salute.
I mean it was very obvious.
I mean the problem for me there with that podcast frankly was that I feel like
you both got unlucky with w just where he was in his life at that moment.
And because it was like,
yeah.
Cause.
So w what that podcast showcased,
at least for the first,
I don't know,
90 minutes was just how many user interface problems you could have with Ilan.
Right.
Like he did,
he did.
He just showed up as kind of fairly weird.
Right.
He's not,
he's not always like that by any stretch.
I mean,
he can give a very loose interview and you,
but you were working,
I mean it was just absolutely heroic work trying to keep that conversation
happening,
you know,
in the beginning.
But once we got loose,
yeah.
But it was still,
it's like,
you know,
he was just in a space that he,
he was so massively stressed and so overworked and just,
I mean,
he had,
you know,
fires everywhere that had to be put out.
And,
um,
so I just felt,
you know,
as a friend,
I just felt like,
okay,
this is sort of the wrong time to be doing this and this is,
you know,
and so I just felt,
it just felt unlucky to me.
So,
um,
because he's,
uh,
again,
I,
you know,
I see him in,
in many other moments and he can be,
um,
[inaudible] that was out of those actually a circumstance where I was looking at
the comments.
Right.
You know,
and,
and I was saying,
okay,
this is these,
these are people who are basically reading him as somebody who is much stranger
than in fact he,
he ever is.
And I could see why they were doing that because he,
the guy,
he just seemed in a very stressed space in his life.
Well,
it was interesting.
He was very different when you first got here versus when the Mike came on.
Right.
When he first got here,
he pulls out the fucking blow torch and starts shooting this flame thrower in
the middle of the hallway and we're laughing and I'm like,
he's going to be easy.
This is great.
And then we sat down and then death right off the bat.
And,
um,
I'm just trying to massage it and get 'em get 'em get 'em going.
Although,
yeah.